this uh benny shapiro
he's got a pretty big following and he's
also creating some hysteria here because
he's using the term sharia say the women
have rights that comply with sharia that
means women don't have rights
he's using the terms islam uh within the
frameworks of islam under law
and he's sending off a message kind of
like okay
now
if anything has to do with sharia islam
that now you know catastrophe's about to
hit and he's using some really
inflammatory language uh out there what
what do you have to say to some of these
things that uh
benny's saying banish saying you know
it's really important
we have to be really cautious uh when
anyone brings you any news the quran
says in chapter 49 surah hujarat verse
number 6
that if any disbeliever brings you a
news investigate so you don't harm
people out of ignorance and you don't
regret it later on
so if someone is saying you know what
sharia says this jihad means that that
part of that
that country that those people are doing
that we have to take it with a grain of
salt we have to investigate first and
foremost so when we investigate
sharia for example
sharia literally it means you know the
guidance that our creator has given for
humanity so we can live
with peace with the creator peace with
other humans
and live in justice and equality and and
unity within all of humanity so that's
what sharia means
sharia is not about oppressing women or
taking you know
uh oppressing uh the people who are
non-believers sharia gives rights
equal rights uh to the women
so if someone is saying you know what
sharia we have to blame uh we have to
blame the taliban because they want to
implement the sharia
first and foremost taliban are no angels
they're not perfect if they're doing
anything wrong and they are obviously we
have to blame them and not islam not
sharia and definitely not the quran
so sharia actually the viewers may be
surprised to find out sharia gave
humongous rights to women
you know the oldest continuous
university in the whole world according
to unesco
it was made by a muslim lady
who was empowered by the sharia sharia
gives muslim ladies
not to be uh forced into marriage
that's a surprise for ben shapiro i
guess sharia gave muslim ladies
that they can initiate a divorce if they
if they want to
they can have their own property
um so all of these humongous rights were
given by the sharia if some country is
not implementing it
we have to blame them and not the
perfect sharia that allah god has given
to us
a couple of points i want to mention
to
benny shapiro i had rabbi shapiro on the
dean's show oh really and he was talking
about
we were talking about touching upon the
jewish sharia
that you many people don't know you have
also christian sharia yes you have also
mentioned in the bible
because many people don't know like
christians and jews who are arabic
speaking they
don't refer to
god as god they've referred to god as
allah
and they have the term also sharia you
have shadia mentioned 200 plus times
in the yeah in the in the uh christian
jewish bible
and this is confirmed you can check i
like i said i had rabbi shapiro and we
touched upon this
so
you had moses
who was and this is great because these
are educational moments we hear these
things and people speaking un
academically and they just you know
going off their whims and their fancies
and desires a lot of people have this
just hate inside their hearts and
they're protected we don't know what's
in their hearts but you can just guess
they're just angry uneducated and now
they're using such inflammatory language
and words just to like rile people up
maybe get their numbers up whoever the
case and it's big business bashing islam
so again like you said we're not
supporting any political party or group
but as soon as you bring in islamic
terms and islam now hold on let's let's
let's fact check you
so these are the things that we
mentioned um that they don't know sharia
it's in the bible 200-plus times moses
moses brought shadia yes if you if you
look at the ten commandments
if you look into the old testament the
book of exodus chapter 20 verse number
three the ten commandments are the
sharia guidance that prophet moses peace
be upon him
right a mighty prophet that he brought
from god to the people
so we said that is the guidance which is
a humongously beneficial guidance you
know worship only one god do not make
any graven images
be good to your parents do not lie do
not cheat do not murder all of these are
sharia guidance we say that were given
by god to prophet moses and his people
so yes sharia is there in the old
testament and sharia guidance is there
in the new testament and then the last
prophet of god muhammad peace be upon
him he was given the complete guidance a
complete sharia
using that humanity can prosper get
united be moral be just and peace would
be there between humanity definitely
between humanity and the creator yeah we
want to give credit where credit is due
like for instance angelina jolie yeah
she was at one point i believe she was
speaking out and creating awareness for
the greatest genocide that happened
after world war ii in bosnia you had
rape camps set up there and you had the
chutneys and these were people their
priests were blessing their guns
you know and they were doing this on
behalf of christianity that's what they
thought but we know that this had
nothing to do with jesus as christianity
but they are christian the chutneys and
they were doing some uh really horrific
evil things uh in srabanitsa where many
people don't know you can look this up
and this is a whole different topic but
when people are doing good we're gonna
commend that good of course so this is
very important now she's coming out
hopefully she has a good intention she's
trying to do some good we invite her to
come on to the dean's show and she could
talk about this and even uh benny
shapiro we bring him on
and let's have a conversation it's very
important to have these conversations to
fact check things so people don't walk
away thinking like okay sharia you know
boogie man coming to get me islam
backwards oppresses women you know
you know a human being and we could
touch upon this a human being will make
grave errors make mistakes
they might end up or a group of human
beings might end up oppressing
a uh society of people but islam can
never be oppressive
it could never be that's the example of
prophet muhammad peace be upon him
that's the example coming from the quran
you know one example that we can give to
ben shapiro for example
that there is a synagogue in afghanistan
that has been there for literally
centuries when taliban came to power
they actually protected it they gave the
jews and afghanistan a right
to openly go and pray in there right so
the jews have the
they have the autonomy to have their own
culture their own synagogue their own
freedoms and that was the example coming
from also prophet muhammad peace be upon
him
when he went from makkah to madina in
the very first migration he found a
big number of jews up there
so what he did was he made a
constitution with them called as the
madinah charter
and in the charter it says that the jews
and the muslims would be one people we
are going to look out for each other and
the jews you have your own synagogues
your own culture your own freedoms your
own punishment system your own justice
system so there was a so they were a
autonomous
jewish state within the true islamic
state
so that is uh
the gold standard
that that we need to follow that's the